[موسيقى]
مدينه طنجه قلب السياحه النابض في الشمال
المغربي
تعيش المدينه حاله من الانتعاش والرواج
الاقتصادي على وقع مشاركتها العاصمه
الرباط في استضافه بطوله كاس العالم
للانديه لكره القدم
مدينه جميله المدينه السياحيه المدينه
التي تفتخر بالمئاتي التاريخيه ديالها
الزوار بزاف
واللي مجازي المدينه العتيقه ديال مدينه
طنجه
تتصدر الفنادق قائمه القطاعات التي
استنفرت كل طاقاتها اللوجستيه والبشريه من
اجل ايواء ضيوف طنجه في افضل الظروف
كسفنا زيدنا في المجهودات خاص لهذا
الحفل اللي لنا الشرف كيما قلت لك في
الاول الحمد لله والشكر لله بلادنا
يستضف هاد العرس الرياضي الكبير
المونديالتو
الاسواق والمحلات التجاريه بمختلف انواعها
تحاول هي الاخرى ان تحقق رواجا اقتصاديا
من خلال عرض منتجاتها لاسيما تلك التي
تحمل خصوصيه محليه
واحنا فرحانين بهم دائما هيدا ناشطنه ويجي
بنادم ويمشي بنادم الدنيا وكيوقع الرواج
وبحكم موقع طنجه الساحر على واجهتين
بحريتين الاولى على المحيط الاطلسي
والثانيه على البحر الابيض المتوسط لا
يمكن لمن يزور المدينه ان يفوت فرصه
الاستمتاع بوجبات السمك الشهيه التي
توفرها مجموعه من المطاعم المتخصصه كهذا
المطعم الذي زاره عدد كبير من المشاهير
خصوصا في عالم السياسه والفن والرياضه عهد
مونديال توم سعد ان شاء الله وفتح واحد
الافاق من الضيوف الضيوف كاملين ان شاء
الله
من المشاهير من رجال الاعمال من الناس من
سفراء من من ملعبيه الكره تبارك الله
بطولات كره القدم ليست فقط مباريات
وجماهير لكنها قد تكون بالنسبه لكثير مما
يتهمون وظائف مرتبطه بالسياحه فرصه لا
تعوض لتحقيق مكاسب اقتصاديه تعود بالخير
على الجميع حمزه الراضي الجزيره طنجه